how about we talk about what it means to
be a real man yeah the conversation
rights the coronavirus reveals just how
deep macho stereotypes run through
society and you know what I actually saw
in that headline yada yada grumble
mumble social justice nonsense
coronavirus nailed it that's all I read
that now that's all I see
blah blah blah social justice social
justice we can do horn our ideology into
anything
macho Steve now this is how we know that
the pandemic is coming to an end it's
started it's back on the rise again
we're running out of things to talk
about so they're putting this stuff back
in and I am very happy to say that while
we still are talking about the pandemic
as you mentioned we're on the downswing
you know so we get to pretend to be
angry at them being pretending to be
angry about
macho stereotypes I mean that only some
why I think we're angry a little bit so
let's let's be fair and see what they
have to say cuz maybe we'll agree with
them maybe there's always a chance
here's what the conversation rights
early indications suggest more men are
dying from kovat 19 than women strong
start although some countries including
the UK are not publishing data on this
experts are unsure exactly why this
might be it may it may in part be due to
differences in biology so jetsons have
been made for example it might be
because men and women have a different
immune response and that men's immune
systems may not activate in the same way
as women's to fight the virus but
lifestyle and behavior are also likely
to play a role for a start men are more
likely to have underlying health
problems relevant to kovat 19's just
high blood pressure cardiovascular
disease and some chronic lung diseases
this is in part because men are more
likely to engage in risky behavior such
as smoking drinking and drug taking
is that a macho stereotype I don't know
research also seems to indicate that
some men may take personal hygiene just
hand-washing less seriously than women I
agree this could be due to the fact that
cleanliness is often associated with
femininity domestic City and
beautification
okay now you tell you lost me I think it
has to do more with guys not caring
they're lazy they roll out of bed they
don't take a shower they slap a hat on
their grease
heads and they're like let's go skate
that's about it
yep no care it has nothing to do with
like oh no if I wash my hands I might be
a woman I don't think any dude has ever
thought that nope maybe yeah I mean I
can only speak for myself maybe I have
not thought that maybe you know in the
1200 s I will not be a dainty flower and
wash my hands I'm a warrior
however the writer carolyn creado perez
has also pointed out that because most
medical research focuses on male bodies
oh here we go
there is a lack of understanding about
why women may be better able to fend off
this virus now hold on there the
conversation this is a particularly
transphobic assessment women's bodies
women can be born male hmm well I'm
really if we're gonna go by the standard
set of social justice narratives this is
very confusing yeah they're trying to
talk about feminine feminine femininity
male behaviors but our I don't know I
I'm very confused by what the point is
anymore because this ideology makes it 0
cents well and they started this article
by saying expert are unsure exactly why
this may be it's like what so wait you
lead with we don't know exactly why the
art of the title of the article says
this but I'm gonna give you all my
opinion on it that's what I read from
there so and what you just read is just
like yep exactly
you know you think they they have a
story here oh they're linking to
slate.com oh cool it's late is that late
is regressive leftist great yeah yeah
so I'm when they mentioned that men you
know sore that cleanliness is associated
with femininity de mis DISA tea and
beautification I'm like what's their
source cuz they did put a source ah its
slate the regressive left website one
strike you know to be fair slate did
write correctly about my trip to Sweden
only because it benefited them
politically in the beginning so so it's
funny though because we feel that people
like rag on me for going to Sweden and
reporting what I did I'm like I don't
know slate and Huffington Post said I
was right here's what they write
loneliness and social isolation the
kovat 19 pandemic has also highlighted
the different roles men and women are
still expected to play in society men
are not only less ly
to take care of themselves but also less
likely to be involved in caring for
others it is striking how much women are
depended on to deliver both low paid and
unpaid care work weather for children
disabled people older people or those in
ill health
indeed the pandemic is placing
additional caring responsibilities on
women I'm curious about their assessment
of this a woman taking care of her own
child
right that's the unpaid caretaking right
yeah I don't think women are going off
on routine to like work at daycares for
no money right yeah okay correct so that
they're slotting this in under being a
mother right that's what I'm like what
if the woman got a job in the men I
don't know like I don't understand how
this is like an issue for you you have
kids who take care of them
congratulations you're a parent and if
you're lucky your parents live a long
time and you might have to take care of
yeah - yeah kovat 19 is forcing people
to reflect upon a human fragility
mutuality and interdependence
here come the the weird adjectives and
pronouns but gender norms also require
men to be invulnerable always strong and
self-sufficient does it's men who also
tend to socialize more in groups in
public may take social distancing less
seriously than women they may find it
difficult to accept they need help -
seeing it as unmanly to do so where's
that source from what is this but wait
what you just completely lost me Chrome
unlike no pro mundo global organ
masculine norms and men's health making
the connections executive summary that's
their source no I I if I'm gonna do a
job and I need to help doing it I'm not
gonna do that job I'm gonna go find
someone to help me these are not I like
I like getting other ideas because
sometimes mine aren't the best this is
what we were talking about yesterday why
male feminists are real men
exactly yeah they're not it's it's a
it's a lie right they're pretending to
be tough and just saying what they think
they need to say that's not real man or
manly exactly most guys I know who are
regular guys don't think this way at all
it's a weird caricature it is weird it's
like it's like feminists got together
and started talking about like start
drawing a picture it's like who make the
eyes really big now make his cheeks
really high okay make us make us make us
brow really curl and they're drawing
this picture where they're all pitch
weird things you know they take bits of
every every person they've ever hated
and mashed all together and they've like
drawn Gaston you know I think computing
the Beast yeah oh yeah yeah older men in
particular are more likely to experience
loneliness and social isolation what's
your source on that one
Bristol dot a seat at UK but that I
believe and this could put them an
increased risk of mental health problems
okay that's terrible
gender norms also expect men to be
powerful and in control so while many
men may relish the opportunity to be
more involved at home some have used it
to assert more dominance and control
over their partners and children this is
RIT this is so weird it's really it's
getting further and further down the
hall yeah that's that's the goal though
because they know if regular people read
it and you'll start with a crazy first
yeah they'll be like I'm out so you
gotta you got a rope um in yeah all
right what is this yeah please oh oh
there it is patriarchy oh yes we made it
of course
further down tripped and started rolling
and smack faith into the patriarchy
these patriarchal discourses can have
serious implications for government
policy such as encouraging or overly
militaristic authoritarian approaches
and prioritizing male-dominated sectors
the economy and society
for instance women are more likely to be
in temporary informal or precarious work
which falls outside the protected
protection packages being established
you know what man so women don't choose
to be petroleum engineers we need
petroleum for the economy to function
for cars and then they're complaining
that we're not prioritizing there aren't
there they're not as necessary job how
important is it for some of the work
that they're doing probably important
you and the reason well for specific
jobs sure but there's a reason why some
things are paid more than others like
high risk yeah or high necessity yeah so
if you if you're not working in
petroleum engineering which is a very
important role in sustaining the economy
as much as environmental so might not
like we'd like to hear it then don't be
surprised when the government doesn't
say we're gonna make you know feminists
dance class and essential function we're
going to subsidize all feminists
interpretive dance lessons why would
they do that okay I know I'm
exaggerating but you know they are
as part of the argument that if you're a
mother you should be paid to something
yes if you have a kid they call it
unpaid and they call it emotional labor
who should pay you I the government the
government the government should pay me
because I had kids I mean they kind of
do that in what what country is hungry
was hungry yeah if you have more than a
certain number of children you get a tax
break yeah yeah a tax refund hmm all
right here's what they say more broadly
this crisis is a huge opportunity to
reassess political priorities and gender
relations it offers the chance to
overturn years of neglect by recognizing
the essential contribution of care to
society this will not only help to
encourage men to play their part but it
will go some way towards shifting
harmful gender norms in the aftermath of
the kovat 19 pandemic you know we though
we did a video and if you guys missed
this video go watch it because there's
so much that we can say but we've said
it we've had this conversation so many
times and what I'm really thinking of
right now is is that what was that video
that we said who are the real privileged
in the society yeah it's it's women yeah
well and we explain it though we go
through it in depth
in this video right and and there's a
there's an age level and it changes all
that it changes through the year so it's
not always true yeah but for the most
part it is well no no it's early on yeah
early so early on it's right and as it
gets as they get older I get less and
less important and that's the the louder
and louder mouth so the general general
problem my hypothesis is that so we when
you look at the data dating data from
like OkCupid right look at other data
you can see that young women mm-hmm have
are the baseline for highest possibility
societal value and young men are as
young men start off as a zero quite
literally and young young women start
off at 100 from us on a scale of 0 to
100 over time young men having no status
they're not strong they're not tall
they're not developed no money no money
no job right they're very very low in
seidel value yeah but yeah
women are very high for obvious reasons
child rearing and healthy birthing and
things like this whether whether the
feminists want to admit it that's what
the the evolutionary psychologists have
pointed out and over time as young men
become more experienced more capable
more skilled more wealthy they start
becoming more and more valuable and
considering that a man can have kids
well into like his 70s he wants that
relate see what he wants as long a Jun
still shoots it takes men a long time to
grow but here's the thing a man in his
30s around 33 or 34 becomes the most
valuable they will ever be mm-hmm and it
doesn't get anywhere near the top so a
young women will always women will
always have more value to society based
on certain data sets right then a man
ever could but around their mid-20s I
think around 28 or 29 men and women
invert men are going up and passing
women who go down in value yeah but
there is there's a fair point to make in
that the value for women was never about
their careers their minds their
abilities it was always about their
buddy to have kids
so the value they did have as young
people might not be the value they
wanted it's about their looks isn't it
well right and it's a combination of
factors but looks like so a man looks at
a woman he's trying to see you know when
it comes to evolution who's gonna have
good kids right now I don't need to know
if you're smart or not kind better there
there's some but not all no but it
actually does play a really big role the
reason why 22 is the most sought-after
age for all men is because of life
experience so you want to know something
really really creepy I guess they did a
blind study I don't know who they is it
was I was reading this article about it
where they showed images of women and
asked men to rate who do you think is
the most attractive out of all these
women and guess what the age was 22 no
really go down no no yeah go down
younger yep yeah really yep I don't want
to guess yeah because it's under 18 I
don't and this what people don't realize
get that because I I mean looking at if
you were to look at like ten to a
hundred and the years there's a point
where you know like 24
you kind of look more adult ish
and under that it's not even attractive
anymore to me it's just childish now
what I was reading was that I don't get
it 22 is the prime age because it's
young but you're like an adult
okay so men didn't want to be around
someone who was a child who was going to
act like a child so when they were given
images of women but weren't told their
ages and left to make assumptions they
chose very very young age you really
want to know everyone's now guessing in
the chat so let's see what do they get
16 14 14 it was 49 48 gosh you know you
want know something even grosser no you
ever go away don't you ever go to a
Molly thumb with Lydia yeah you ever go
to a mullet you've been to a mall right
I've been to a mall all right you know
you ever walked past those like lingerie
shops and you see the beautiful men and
their underwear on the on the Sun you
know sure you've seen like ads with
models for like perfume and stuff you
know I've been in them and you know old
these women are right I've yes and you
know many of them are 14 15 it's not all
the time actually so I mean it depends
actually because I actually know because
I was in that world and I worked with
these specific models and they weren't
doing I would say of the jobs that I did
the average age was probably like 20
years old 20 20 there were some ads I
mean yes there was very few time to say
about 2% of the jobs that I did and I
modeled for a long time doing like the
two could it could it be that it's
because you were older that they had you
working in similar spaces with people
who are old enough no I mean I did I did
American Eagle three times
and it was like I they wanted everyone
to look young you know so it's like they
got but there was always like 20 year
olds 22 24 year olds you know but I've
never worked with anyone under the age
of 18 I've been on a bunch of sets
uh-huh and I don't want to violate
anyone's privacy by getting into too
much detail okay but it's a young man
because I sure I mean I was that was my
main job but I'm 15 years so I know what
I'm talking about
and I could say exactly this I've been
on a bunch of sets where the women were
all underage okay so I'm wondering if
the reason you were on sets with women
or older is because you were at you had
a certain look and they wanted that to
match versus putting a woman in a bra
and panties and taking pictures of her
you know where the the young that I saw
the young models what they were doing
runway and it's it's a different it's a
different environment runway modeling to
like print modeling it is two completely
different things and print modeling
Mencia lot of of younger under underage
models it I have seen it I'm not saying
it doesn't exist I did see it but not
much not not as much when ingesting I
mean the experience I've had
mm-hmm have you been a model model in
law I want to Elaine got a lot of
experience modeling to avoid violating
the privacy of certain individuals I'm
gonna dismissive boy I've been on many
sets okay I've been in I've seen a lot
of it right now and I've looked at ads
and been like my oh my god yeah
and I've had agents be like you know
that well you know old that girl is the
one who's got like her bra falling off
and she's squeezing 14 I've been in I've
been in in these offices where the
agencies are talking about who they're
booking and why they're booking it okay
and that's why I'm asking I'm wondering
if it's like you as like with a certain
look they were like we're gonna have
women who fit your style and maybe that
was your experience I guess I mean I
believe that my main profession Forbes
I'm not saying literally every single
thing all the time yeah but a lot of
these ads that I've been you know there
are young women they're underage and but
they look it's funny but they look older
though those 14 year olds 15 16 year
olds that you're bragging about look of
a certain age and that's not that's it's
it's rare to get the on-camera look that
they want of that younger age and
usually it's not American it's not
usually not American girls it's usually
from other countries but yeah it's young
it well whatever that data that's that's
the thing I was reading was like nuts
and also the thing I was reading from
OkCupid mm-hmm
about like peak societal value they
think they they don't they don't allow
people to evaluate people under 18 so it
like started at 18 as like a hundred
then went down yeah but there was some
other study I was reading where they
were like we just took a bunch of images
and asked men to rate them and what I
was reading from that was they mentioned
something about the age of models and
why models are chosen who are typically
very young
for these reasons because without
knowing anything about them men are like
oh that's that's you know that's
attractive it's interesting there is a
direct correlation with what you were
talking about how women started 100 and
go down and men start at a zero and go
up and in in the modeling world is the
exact same way yep you know all my
friends that are girl models they are
always talking about like I really need
to maintain I need to stay in shape like
I got a I like competitions getting
rough you know I'm not getting booked as
much and then the guys I know some guys
that are still modeling and they're in
their 50s now yep you know it's like I
mean I guess I guess it depends on what
you're doing because women could switch
to lifestyle or something or catalog
that's true yeah and then it's like then
you're the mom then you're the grandma
yep and they're still looking for it
exists but those jobs tend to be I
already have them right filled you know
yeah yeah so like a dude will be alike
oh great I'm getting gray coming in and
like ooh that's great we could use that
yeah and the women are like oh god my
wrinkles what do I do
you know that's what I'm growing this
beard out now I'm just kidding I don't
know no model anymore thanks for
checking out this clip from the Tim cast
IRL podcast we do the show live Monday
through Friday at 8 p.m. if you want to
catch the full show tune into this
channel subscribe hit the like button or
check us out on iTunes and Spotify and
we will soon have this podcast up for
free on all podcast platforms thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all in the
next episode
you